hey everyone
welcome i'm super excited
to be doing a stream on
walter russell and the universal one
i'm very grateful because andy bittner
ended up introducing me to walter
russell
and i have loved going through
this book and his work
and i'm excited to share it with you and
i actually have a great
setup where i'm going to be able to show
you
on an over the shoulder shot
much of the key points as we go through
it
so let's let's jump
right in so i'd like to
start things off by indicating how
walter russell is
adamant about how mind equals
light which equals
matter and energy
and
similarly one god
the universal one
how great geniuses of the ages
have been men of supervision
and how they are usually only worshiped
when they're dead
and man can produce nature's elements in
exactly the way
nature itself produces them
this book was published in 1927.
as soon as man stops its jungle habits
and settles his human relations by more
peaceful methods
we can advance we need a consistent
cosmogeny
walter russell spent a full seven years
in writing this book
and its mix of science and metaphysics
we need intuition we need to go beyond
rationality be super irrational
have faith in the infinite
we need to be knowing man instead of
sensing man
increase awareness of our relation
to source
i'm just gonna zoom out a bit
hopefully that's still okay for people
to read
i'm figuring out how to optimally do
these read-alongs
about the key points
again these are the most salient things
that i've taken
out of my exegesis and
so you as well will have your own
drawing out of the most salient points
and i put the links in the bio below to
the university of science and philosophy
as well as their books where you can
check out the other writings of walter
russell
we have to go deeper and deeper into the
invisible and unseen
the why of things
the senses cannot fathom but the
consciousness can
beyond that range lies the cause of it
the why of it
prana awakening within man and awareness
of the source
orderliness symmetry and balance which
all nature expresses
nature perpetually polarizes and
depolarizes in its every expression
breathings but you are not aware of it
again that's the prana
that is life the fulcrum from which
all power springs is knowledge when man
has that omniscience
unfolding in cosmic man he will no
longer misuse break or disobey god's law
he will command it he will know the law
you have opened the door into the
infinite now science must enter
physicist type of mind could never
fathom the mystery of the universe the
great story the great inspiration of
some poet painter
philosopher or saint will be the one to
explain it as long as man neglects
to honor his geniuses who are engaged
in the arts of peace and glorifies his
heroes who are most proficient in the
arts of war the human race will continue
to suffer
the agonies of its own making
god loving men the law of love is
rhythmic balanced interchange between
all things boom i love those three words
and andy had definitely prioritized
my awareness of them as well rhythmic
balanced
interchange all things are light
light separates not nor has it bounds
nor is it here and not there
new age of knowledge and awareness of
our oneness with all life
all right mathematical and measurable
proof
of the existence of but one mind one
force one substance
power to create as god creates
man is god man is mind man is matter
mind and matter are one god is mind
universe is a multiplicity of changing
effects
one unchanging cause one universe one
mind one force one
substance knowledge
is not acquired from without but merely
recollected from within
boom electromagnetic process of thinking
mind
think in light electromagnetic
periodicities
think in light from within open the
doors of all knowledge
omnipotence lies in perfect thinking
matter is light nothing is which is not
light
all things are answerable in light the
universe
is a tonal one a dimensionless universe
of light
high octaves of the inner mind
spirit ecstatic man is inspired man of
universal genius of inner thinking
work which is created an ecstasy of
inner thinking can alone endure
dimension disappears in light then he is
superman
then he is universal genius light is the
universal language in which the divine
concept
is plainly written truth as plainly told
in light
the universal language of light
and here are some of the epic visuals
that we'll also be unpacking as we go
periodicity is an absolute
characteristic of all phenomena of
nature
it's the p russell periodic chart of
atomic weights
electromagnetic charge gravitation
radiation sex temperature electric
magnetic pressures valence ionization
and other periodicities
the universe is not a separate creation
of gods it is god
a perfect and omnipotent god could not
create imperfection
this is a creating universe periodic
change of state of the one unchanging
substance
it is evolution
god is thinking mind substance or body
of god is light one universal substance
which is god
thinking substance mind is expressed in
light
the one substance is the etheric
spiritual substance of the one universal
mind
god and matter are one spirit and matter
are the same substance that substance is
light
one life in the universe one living
breathing pulsing being
the universe and all that is is one
again that very
deep drive towards the universal one
the law of one and how it is a rhythmic
balanced interchange
life is the pulsing electromagnetic
oscillation of thinking mind
all life is immortal life no matter is
lifeless
life has no beginning life has no ending
life is eternal
life is in and of all inorganic as well
as all
organic matter life is the
effect produced on the substance of mind
by the sequence of alternating
electromagnetic pulsations which can
constitute the process of thinking all
growing things
are imbued with the life principle all
things are growing things all matter is
evolving
all matter is growing all matter is
living
all motion is motion in equilibrium
no other motion is possible boom motion
and inertia motion and opposition matter
is motion in opposition matter equals
motion
in opposition
motion in inertia is equally electric
and magnetic
there is no death life is eternal
oscillatory motion is a pulsating in
breathing and
out breathing
father mother forces of mind one force
all matter is but a variation of the
state of light
human mind equals scale invariant
microcosm
of sunlight at the macrocosm as above
so below with light
matter and mind and light and energy are
eternal they are constant they
are cause form and motion are illusions
they are fleeting
they are effects
very similar to the perennial spiritual
wisdom that's been taught for thousands
of years
of the absolute is the formless
is the agentless is the attributeless
ocean meanwhile
the the downstream
forms of the waves on the ocean
are the physicalism that we find
ourselves
in and that we are infinitely
exploring the creativity and the
expression of the absolute
ocean expressing itself as those waves
mind is the universe it is all that
is ever was or ever will be the
substance of mind is the foundation of
creation it is the seed of the universe
seed of the universe is the whole of the
universe all intelligent all powerful
and all present
without motion and opposition neither
heat color
cold sex mass or any of the effects of
thinking could be or appear to be
all these elements are made up of light
units in maximum motion and opposition
and we talked about this when david
johnson dj was on the show who's another
close friend of andy who's working
on simulation design with his company
argos vue
and the actual vue technology itself
that enables us to do things like
simulate the light units as these
fundamental
units and then be able to he's working
with people like terence howard on these
theories of everything around
what walter russell hypothesizes as
light units
and then i have another view for these
big graphics
that will help
all right so
there is but one cosmic substance
one mind and then the
split here evolution the concentrative
desire of mind
dissolution is the decent trait of
desire of mind
and this is out of the one and this
is back into its source in the one
and so the universal substance divides
itself into the appearance
of two opposites
and again this is my exegesis of it many
states of motion
are possible but there are not two
substances in the universe
and there's a lot more to unpack in
these graphics
and i'll do my best to
explain as i go of what i drew out of it
and then you yourself are gonna have to
undergo a process if you're interested
in diving deeper into also walter
russell's work the universal one and
again the links in the bio below go and
support them
and buy yourself a book and draw out
your own most salient points from what
he's saying here
but this is extremely aligned with the
perennial spiritual wisdoms
and extremely aligned with the
metaphysics
of the those perennial spiritual
traditions as well as what science even
is kirk currently pointing towards
today creation is merely a swing of the
cosmic pendulum from inertia
through energy and back again to inertia
forever and ever a series of opposing
pulsations
and the reason why i'm going through the
book this way
is because it's really difficult even to
draw out
what has most profoundly affected me and
then to explain that to you
without you seeing what walter
had written along the way and so
it's almost better for me to go through
the book this way
of showing you exactly what he wrote and
my
how i drew out the salience from it and
then for you to simultaneously
be able to draw out the salience from
this as well it almost gives you a wider
range of options on the buffet
and i thought that that was going to be
better than doing
just my main key takeaways
from it because you'll also see my main
key takeaways throughout
the book as well
one universal mind is a formless
thinking substance
thinking is an action which is the cause
of all motion
thinking leaves the evidence of that
process behind it registering the effect
of its passage through the ocean of the
universal mind
again and here's the law on one side the
positive electricity on the other side
the negative electricity
the positive seeks higher pressures the
negative seeks lower pressures
and so there's a magnetic flow
an inhalation and an exhalation this is
the cosmic pendulum
and i wrote here the secret of universe
is in your breath
prana
again that's a very perennial spiritual
wisdom
is that it's as simple as the
that polarity of inhalation and
exhalation or of electromagnetism
or of general radiation that style of
thinking
centrifugal and centripetal force
there's all these male female day-night
sort of dualities that are transcended
by the universal one
but that is the way that it is expresses
itself
through that pendulum swing between the
two
and a flux of the ratios as they express
themselves as the waves on the ocean
the passage of big boats and little
boats and all the winds
upon the tranquil ocean of waters there
you go
again the same spiritual perennial
metaphor that's used
disappear back into the substance of
which they are apart
the difference in time is but relative
time is
nothing in eternity
giant sons have radiated their heat to
the absolute
zero they seize all appearance of
individual existence
substance is as eternal as mind as
eternal
and again here's another way to view it
the creation
and the decreation so in this case it'd
be something like
that
on the creation it's the concentrate of
contractive
pressures of the centripetal force of
thinking this is a lot like
earth or like company centralization and
then on the other side you have
decreation
which is a lot like the decent
decentrative
expansive pressure of the centrifugal
force and the centrifuge is what
separates substances of different
densities this is like
the metaverse this is like
decentralization
and here's one of the famous
illustrations of walter russell and i
wrote here subatomic atomic
chemistry biology all in one energy
field ocean
electromagnetic flux ascending to
attractor
of metaverse recursion
one complete cycle of the transfer of
the universal constant of energy
into and through all of its dimensions
in sequence
that man can comprehend all that man can
comprehend of this universe
can be spelled out in their beginnings
on these two opposing spiral waves
within one sphere
the force called thinking which
impels mind into concentration and
decentration and sequence is the only
energy of the universe the universe is
mind only
time begins with the action of thinking
life
is eternal again this is very much
deeply idealism but
it's also the synthesis
of idealism
with its physical
immersion into the reality because it's
not
two it's one the consciousness is not
to it's not observer and physical
they're one and that's the point
it's the same thing that's been trying
to be communicated
for the longest periods of time now
life is merely the action of thinking
the tempo of the cosmic rhythmic meter
of thinking is absolute
all motion is action and reaction
opposites known as generation and
radiation i love that the generation and
radiation
this part's great generation is the
attractive gravitative positive electric
force and radiation is the repulsive
emanative
negative magnetic force all motion is in
equilibrium
thinking is the electrogenerative action
and magneto
radiative reaction of mind boom
thinking is a simple process of very
complex effects
the electromagnetic opposition of mind
as expressed in the process of thinking
is the source of all of the energy of
the universe
the inertial line or plane
dead center between force and force
where no force exists
i'm so pumped to explain this the
universe breathes
inhaling and exhaling as man breathes
exhalation and inhalation in sequence is
a characteristic of all phenomena of
matter
the former centripetal and its direction
is toward
the nuclear center of a closing spiral
the ladder is centrifugal away from the
center toward the opening spiral
their difference is but a rising or
lowering of potential
general activity builds the elements
radioactivity tears them apart
apparently separate particles in motion
light units spiral
genero radiative waves are the medium of
reproduction of idea throughout the
entirety of the universe
all idea of mind produced by thinking
is measurable waves of electromagnetic
opposition
again there's the highlight for me a
critical one
general radiative
waves interchange rhythm balance
all right everything is electromagnetic
general radiative interchange of god's
mind
of which we are nerve endings
all motion is spiral and direction is
curved
so in this case it's like uh let's start
here
so the law to every action there is an
equal and opposite reaction aka newton's
third law of classical mechanics
and then
let's go down here next
all mass is accumulated centripetally by
the general active
gravitative attractive power of
electricity
and is dissipated centrifugally by the
radioactive repelling power of magnetism
the greater the mass the greater the
potential
a lot of this is also similar to gaining
spiritual mass
and over time becoming more and more of
a beacon of that god consciousness
so here's a good way to visualize it
right
so you can think about it this is a way
that i'm
understanding it where each oxygen slash
nitrogen molecule
in the sky has this between them this
inertial plane
of equal pressures which lies between
any two masses
and that can also be thought of
similarly as when you finish your
that stopping point at the inhalation
and then
stopping point stopping point
stopping point and so this can also be
thought of similarly like when we had
frank chester on the show and he talked
about his chestahedron
which is like where we have our heart
the lub dub
lub dub that
constant systolic diastolic where you
have
a a high amount of pressure as the heart
sends the fresh oxygenated blood
throughout the body
and then as a diastolic dubs and then it
has that lower pressure where it's
taking
in both what has already distributed
oxygen so the deoxygenated blood to then
pump that out
to the lung capillaries for there to be
a the alveoli for there to be
the exchange again with the
environment and so that's very similar
with the o2
and the co2 is very similar to the
blood glucose homeostasis that happens
throughout the body
where you have the pancreas secreting
both
insulin and glucagon and also the eye
accommodation that happens
and this is very similar it's like if
you put the heart
and the lungs on each end of this
infinity
you literally have infinity within you
and it's clear as day it's right under
our nose
and this is a really interesting
fascinating way to sort of look
at the forces that are at play
and there's very few people that are
able to explain it
at this depth and that's one of my
favorite parts about
walter very polymathic
all the elements of matter are but
orderly and periodic variations of the
one substance
light innumerable states
of so-called speeds of light
and here's another visualization where
you have
on one side you have this centrifugal
force
of repellative and on the other side you
have the centripetal force of
gravitative
and so it's very much like this action
and reaction
you have these balances of the
accelerative decelerative
and the equalization you have the
energy and the inertia you have the
instability and the stability
there are no opposites the totals of any
two
opposing forces added together make one
boom
and that's another sort of really good
way to
think about it as well is that those two
poles
they make one but it's definitely
expressed as those two poles
relativity is the science of an illusion
in four dimensions as
perspective is in three god is light
the inner mind of ecstatic man knows the
real light
and that he is one with light he is not
deceived by its illusion
appearances have become as facts and the
one reality has become mere conjecture
man must learn to alter his concept of
the reality of solidity to the reality
of mind
as the source of the illusion of that
solidity
the one substance of mind is the one
reality
form in matter as but the registration
of his thinking
mind is omnipresent omniscient and
omnipotent
he is mind a conditioned
fact cannot be a fact it merely appears
to be a fact
the universe of man is but a
kaleidoscope turning ever turning
and complexing with its turning
the universe of form is a universe of
integration disintegration and
reintegration
this chapter is on the sex principle
it's so interesting your time to have a
kid
might only be when their soul is ready
kind of like the spark in pixar recent
film soul sex is the apparent
division of the father-mother substance
of mind into apparent opposites
sex is the active desire of mind for
division into opposites and its reactive
desire for unity
sex is that motive force which demands
separability into two and equally
desires union of the apparent two into
one
fascinating nothing can be without the
desire to be
desire dominates all thinking desire
dominates all matter
all desire is sex desire wow
the continuance of existence
and a lot of the world's most famous
renowned
biologists have been articulating this
very similarly from the lens of
physicalism
that much of what even from a
psychological
level as well much of what is our
tendencies is around the thinking mind
to procure the most optimal mate
in the two coming to one
that union that then portals in another
whirlpool of consciousness in the ocean
sex force is the builder of the
apparently many things out of the
totality of the reality of the one thing
the one expresses itself as two coming
together to portal in more desire to no
slash express itself
the material substance of mind cannot
evade its materialization into the form
desired by mind
sex and life and light and intelligence
are
in and of all things from the beginning
all form appears through sex passes
through a progressive change called
growth and disappears
all growth is impelled by force and
motion and controlled by sex
there can be no motion without the force
of thinking
without union in mating
the idea of any one thing would be
extinct as an appearance
sex force and motion the whole idea of
all things is in the seed of all things
in the seed of idea
is the whole of idea in the seed of the
oak is the whole
of the oak and this is what we talk
about with recursion and the logistic
map
people come together to portal a new
consciousness then grow apart
and what we mean by this is that the
cyclic cosmology is never evolving to be
a determinism
of the actual creative process the
attractor
is cyclical and deterministic but the
actual creative
bayesian cloud of possibilities is
completely based on the exploration
of god through us
all idea is registered in the little
particles
heretofore referred to as light units
these units of light heat sex
electricity and magnetism are all male
and all female
every unit is either predominant
preponderantly male
or preponderantly female just so as
every unit either preponderantly
electric or preponderantly magnetic
negative
positive generative radiative
each unit is all of these each unit
is variable
and the variability is orderly and
governed by measurable laws of
periodicity
which are also the laws by which motion
is governed all that
man calls creation is the result of
motion which is due to the opposing
impulses of thinking
opposing desire in sex expression is the
cause of opposing motion opposing
electromagnetic impulses are sex
expression and creative thinking form is
born true to the rhythm of thinking
all thinking is rhythmic thinking all
thinking is sex thinking
creation is the transforming of the one
substance by the rhythmic thinking of
idea
into apparent opposites and into that
which man calls form
beyond this there is no more creation is
but a concept of mind
it is but an illusion an effective
thinking all thinking is registered in
light
all light is sex expression light is the
language of
all thinking light is the energy of
all thinking all energy is the energy of
sex expression
there is no other energy through
evolving sex
light causes the transition of the
universal substance into form
through sex periodicity light transforms
form
into variety of form the universe of
motion is a universe of production
destruction
and reproduction
sex opposites of light
light is the power which god has used to
create the appearance of form
inexhaustible source of energy which
continues matter and motion
fullness of energy available to his
command the rhythm of creative thinking
is absolute
all thinking is creative thinking all
thinking is creating that which
it is thinking god's power of expressing
himself
is in transforming that which is his own
body
into an effect which man calls creation
man's body is but an individual effect
of the whole of man
and is the product of his thinking the
universe is the total
of all individual effects and is the
product of god's thinking
god's thinking is man's thinking all
mind is divine mind
light is god's medium of expressing
himself it is the only medium at his
command
light is man's medium of expressing
himself it is the only medium at his
command
creation of that which man calls form
has a perpetual beginning and a
perpetual ending
it's beginning as in thinking its end is
in thinking
its beginning is its ending
it has no beginning it has no ending no
stop
no break continuity of thinking octaves
of perception
ending disappearance beyond his range of
perception
form is born of the desire to express
idea
form is the play thing of idea all form
is form of sex
idea is never satisfied with form
form of idea is continuously changing
with the process of thinking form is
born anew with each impulse of thinking
idea is reasserted in new form
with each impulse of thinking generative
or male sex thinking radiative or female
sex thinking
regenerative union of sex thinking
equilibrium
of sex idea of mind
may mature or evolve only through
sex union man thinks
idea thinking is the force of motion
all motion is expressed in waves
all waves of motion are both female and
male
all motion is oscillatory action and
reaction action is male reaction is
female all idea is registered in light
as an appearance of the form of idea
form of substance is electromagnetic
this means that it is preponderantly
male and preponderantly female in
periodicity
all idea evolves from idea
into form of idea which in turn devolves
back
again into idea
to evolve idea he must think in light a
union
of these two opposites is the
reproductive force
this is a universe of reproduction
an action and its opposite reaction are
not
two their energies when combined make
one
all idea and all forms of idea are the
result
of union between equal or unequal
opposite actions and reactions of force
in perfection of union lies stability in
imperfection of union lies instability
unstable unions tend to return to their
separate tonal states if either mate in
an unstable union finds a more equal
mate it will always leave the former and
go to the latter
every chemist knows to a certainty that
he can break up any unstable compound
formed by the union of unequal opposites
by merely introducing an element which
is more nearly a true tonal mate to
either
of the united elements
chemically every element is both
alkaline and acid but it is
preponderantly
one or the other
all motion is expressed in waves light
does not travel
it reproduces itself it is the
exact reproduced chemical counterpart of
the star
integrated as light within the observer
no idea of mind is seen
at a distance the state of motion which
represents the idea
is reproduced as light by regenerative
impact
within the observer no idea of mind has
place or position in time or space all
idea is universal
all that is is of everything else that
is
all potential is constantly changing and
interchanging
all mass is degenerated by its own
radiation
all mass is generated by accumulation of
the universal constant of energy
into higher potential that which is
generated must be radiated
no idea of mind once begun ever ends no
idea of mind ever began or ever ended
and here's that visualization
of the induction and the conduction
the positive and the negative
mind is all there is
any continuous line in space would curve
ultimately back to its point
of beginning therefore the universe must
either
must be either spherical or
quasi-spherical
man's fixed concept of the reality of
time is a drag
anchor holding him away from truth
in my opinion that's one of the most
profound aspects
to what walter says here
both ego and time are
the two biggest anchors holding humans
away from truth
as soon as you trash the concept of
time you become eternal
and then you realize that your awareness
is that
we'll be making more content about that
shortly
there are no parts to mind substance no
place
and no position every part is the same
part every place and position is the
same place and position
thinking is universal and all effects of
thinking are universal
sequence is an appearance due to form
adjust his thinking to a subjective
universe in which the unrealities
disappear into the reality of light
einstein's error is an attaching to the
substance of mind the attributes which
belong solely to dimension
of the substance in its appearance as
form
a dimensionless universe dimension is
but an appearance an effective
motion and is non-existent
man must think in light for true
comprehension of mind
man may shift his thinking from the low
speed
of his outer mind to the higher speeds
of his inner mind
at will matter and mind and light and
energy are the same they are one they
are constant they are eternal
the universe of mind is a dimensionless
universe the creating universe is the
idea of mind
it is the divine concept of a universe
of motion and the apparent separability
of the one thing into the appearance of
many individual things
form appears as a result of motion
generated by the
concentrate of impulsive thinking
all motion is controllable by mind all
states of motion are orderly and
periodic
all creation is reducible to about 140
elements
which tell the entire complex story of
god's thinking just as all literature is
reducible to 26 letters
which tell the entire complex story of
all of man's thinking
it's awesome analogy the elements of
matter
are all of the same substance in varying
states of motion
man's labors in the bowels of the earth
for metals which he can create for
himself with ease when he fully
comprehends the motion which has
assembled the forms of those elements
out of the idea of the divine concept
become alchemical gods
there is no substance which nature can
produce that man cannot also produce
and here's a breakdown of the
dimensions here length breadth thickness
duration time
sex pressures potentials temperature
ionization crystallization
valence axial rotation orbital
revolution mass color plane tone
and ecliptic common to all of them is an
orderly periodicity
elements are sorted into about seven
thousand color
lines of light these seven thousand
lines of light are the letters of the
universal language of light
the language in which god speaks to man
he is thinking mind expressing his
thinking in light
that he is omnipotent omniscient and
omnipresent
he is life and that life is eternal and
that there is no death
he has neither place nor position in
space or
time boom within god's alphabet of light
man is mind ma mind creates and controls
the energies of the elements
mind may rearrange these energies and
combine them in a chord with its desire
all dimensions of all effects of motion
are of the same orderly
octave periodicity octave periodicity
and here is an example of the cosmic
clock of his
the formula of the locked potentials
periodicities of inhalation and
exhalation in all mass are absolute
the universal oneness this is the law of
love it is the law of the oneness of the
universe all that is
is one individuality is non-existent
again that's the non-duality
and again here's another view of
similarly that radiation that
gravitation
again gravitation radiation the master
key to the seven lock potentials in each
octave
this is a chart classifying lock
potential points and tones of bound
energy according to their octave numbers
okay
one spiritual substance of divine mind
light is the life principle of
mind light is the creating force of the
universe
light is all that is light is the living
god
god is manifested in light
all is god and god is all god is
light light is all
love is a realization of the oneness of
the universe
love is the ecstasy of inspired thinking
god's thinking
is ecstatic thinking god is love
when man knows this law in his heart he
will have
no limitations when man knows this law
so that its reaction within the soul of
man is that of ecstatic inspired
contemplation
he will then begin to know the meaning
of love unlimited power will then be his
his thinking will then be true thinking
all power
is in true thinking
inspired thinking is thinking in tune
with divinity
thinking in exact pitch with the high
octaves of divine thinking
inner thinking is ecstatic thinking
outer mind cannot know
ecstasy there is no evil there is no
imperfection
absolute infinite perfection
watch our videos on the direct path to
learn more about that
with the realization of this law in his
heart
he will love and be loved of all men and
all created things
all knowledge will come to man when he
knows this law
in his heart inspired man knows the law
of love in his heart with the oneness of
the universe
this inheritance of all knowing awaits
every man to use
as and when he desires that knowledge
omnipresence there is no other god
than mind all idea of mind is perfect
imperfection of mind cannot
exist the one substance of mind is light
all matter is light mind is light
mind is all
integration and disintegration of light
energy into the appearance and
disappearance of that which man calls
matter crystallization of light units
solids of matter
if things are resonating with you and
you want to slow them down and
pause it take notes do that it's really
important to do so
again that's the point of this this is
my exegesis
and then you pause and then you draw out
your salience as well
and you can also order the book from the
link in the bio below
and other walter russell publications
and then do your own
exegesis
the in breathing out breathing impulses
of the living thinking god
mind is an absolute equilibrium
throughout the universe
boom there are no
unconditioned facts of matter in a
universe of motion there are but
appearances of facts
only one infinite creator
the painter with infinite variation
matter as form in motion is but an
ever-changing effect of an unchanging
substance
again unchanging oceanicness
and then the forms and motions as the
ever-changing effects of waves
there is nothing permanent but change
very similar to heraclitus ponte ray
everything flows
and very juxtaposed with classical
parmenides
that all motion is illusory
and that being the beautiful
juxtaposition of the absolute with the
infinite creativity of the physical
all form is constantly in transit
between appearance and disappearance
the ripples on the water effect upon the
substance of water
motion never ends no state of motion
ever ends
becoming is the only beginning again
the absolute as parmenidus
and then the infinite flow as heraclitus
of that creativity nothing is or will be
which has not always been
vapor which disappears from man's sense
of vision
does not cease to be water it can again
reappear to the vision of man
as water the thinking of mind is within
the limitations of the knowledge of mind
again the painter has infinite variation
imperfection or evil is non-existent
again absolute infinite perfection
exploring infinite creativity boom
that's what's going on baby
out of the soul the body is again born
the soul is but the record of man's
thinking
creation is just the swing of the cosmic
pendulum
all appearances and disappearances are
periodic
all things are being again becoming as
the only being
who am i the very important question
that we must ask ourselves as ramana
maharshi
says self-inquiry or atma vichara
is the best path to that
yoga of self-realization
take that seriously drill all the way to
water
and you will uncover the eternal self
that ocean that is constantly expressing
itself as the waves
again exploring infinite expression
and creativity i am the empire
of i am that am i
where i am there god is god is mind
truth
love life light power
i am the master sculptor creator
of all i am an expression of the
universal passion of creation
i love that one i am an expression of
the universal passion of creation
okay
manifestation of recollection known as
imagination
the genius the super thinker with
imagination who brings beauty to the
world
is inspired man thinking in light the
greater the imagination the greater the
perception of the reality of universal
existence hence the greater the
intelligence
the greater the imagination the nearer
to oneness and the farther from the
animal
boom genius is the forerunner of
civilization genius is the bridge
between man and god
genius knows love and truth in all their
fullness
they who attain the ecstasy of genius
are ordained messengers of the universal
one
he who tunes his heart to the messages
of genius purifies himself
no impurity can there be in his heart
for verily he then is in communion with
the holy one
the pure in heart knows their
universality he
who has not ears to hear crucifies
genius the penalty of geniuses
crucifixion
the reward of geniuses immortality
genius desires no reward the glory of
genius is humility genius knows
not the taint of arrogance man has all
knowledge within himself
no exceptions no mistakes no error
all right there is but one
dynamic force gravitation
radiation this one force appears to
divide itself into two
the electricity and the magnetism
of electricity integrate into the
appearance of form and magnetism to
disintegrate
into the disappearance of form integrate
into appearance of form disappearance
of form
they are both the same force electricity
magnetism but they are moving in
opposite directions
energy and energy and inertia here
in between and that comes out as this
complexity
the one force of the universe is the
energy of thinking mind there is no
other energy
again this is really as simple as it
gets
realize that you have both that
absolute that absolute
formlessness and then you have that
physical form
and you just have the dynamic interplay
of that one force appearing to divide
itself into two
there's so many ways to interpret that
and
it's just so beautiful to be able to
make it so simple
a dimensionless reality
physical universe of form is an illusion
light does not travel
light units across octaves
the light unit of the highest octave and
the lowest potential
eventually becomes a light unit of the
lowest octave and highest potential
light units are omnipresent throughout
the universe
and if you want to learn more about the
light units i highly recommend checking
out that episode
with david johnson that we did on
simulation design
on the show and also the way that he's
working on
the light unit theory of everything that
terence howard is
developing as well it's very much
interplayed with
the walter russell understanding
inhalation equals integration exhalation
equals derivation
the sun inhales and exhales inhalation
is regeneration
integration exhalation is dissolution
disintegration
there is no individuality in this
universe of mind there is but an
appearance of individuality
thinking light form
if thinking did not register itself in
light and light did not integrate into
the forms of idea the created universe
would not be
all energy is light and all idea is
light
electricity is the act of attractive
force within mind
magnetism is the reactive repellent
force within the substance of mind
many of these things i chose to write in
the bio for you also because they're key
highlights
electromagnetism equals genero
radiative and that equals centripetal
centrifugal
electricity is the inhalation magnetism
is the exhalation
it's as simple as that it is as simple
as that electricity and magnetism
exist as separate appearances only when
opposed
in non-opposition they disappear they
become one
electricity is therefore centripetal
magnetism is therefore centrifugal
electricity is the generative force
magnetism is the radiative force
again it was very important for me to
not just
have the exegesis where i drew out the
salience and then wrote it out
but i wanted you to literally see
walter russell writing these things out
and i thought that that would be really
helpful for you
and also for your continued
investigation
into the nature of reality
and the more that you pierce this veil
and self-realize
the more you get to the well of
honey that's underneath the rock which
is literally
eternal bliss peace that is our nature
and the coloration of that awareness
infinitely across all these creation
designs
because you deserve 24 7 bliss piece and
not just
five minutes of bliss peace every day
all growth is simultaneously
integrating and disintegrating death
is born in the cradle with life
oh this is great
i'll be unpacking this more on some
coming up videos death is a
stupid limiting concept
so is birth they are both anchoring
us to ignorance
there is no death death is but the
beginning of
life electricity is the vitalizing
property of matter magnetism is the
devitalizing property of matter
electricity is the father the male
principle of thinking mind magnetism
is the mother the female principle of
thinking mind
so this is a an analogy of the
of the kogi and mama nui that i'm using
here
they're the indigenous of the sierra
nevada de santa marta in
colombia electricity is
male younger creative brother
magnetism is female
the older wiser sister
so in many ways that style of
that oceanic-ness that's sort of the
wiser
meanwhile the younger creativity of the
waves just goes out and creates
and that's sort of the balance that we
have right now of the
planetary ecology
and the original living wisdom of the
planet that currently has the
creative human species on it that is
just
creating in all of the metropolises and
all of the
artificial general intelligences and all
the type of stuff that it's doing
electricity craves separation from
magnetism
magnetism desires an equilibrium of
motion and absolute inertia electricity
desires action
right just like we explained a moment
ago
form is fleeting its appearance and
disappearance are periodically repeated
throughout eternity
that's the only way to understand the
nature of our existence
to use these metaphors that are very
explained like i'm five and simple
again the eternal ocean in all of the
different
creative expressions of the waves these
realities
electricity attracts magnetism repels
all mass constantly seeks the proper
pressure zone for its constantly
changing potential
in many ways the absolute is the
formless dimensionless
like magnetism and the infinite
creativity expression of those waves
are like form and dimension like
electricity
so again that younger brother that's
going out and creatively exploring is
like the waves like the electricity
meanwhile the
the older in many ways like sister
of the absolute oceanicness is like that
magnetism
electricity attracts electricity
magnetism does nothing but perform its
function of repelling
it does not attract itself magnetism
is that force within the universal mind
substance which tends to preserve the
oneness of universal uniformity
magnetism desires a formless and
dimensionless universe just as
electricity desires a universe of form
and dimension
magnetism prevents the apparent
separation or division of divine mind
into parts as electricity attempts
this apparent separation
and that's why we talk a lot about
the field and the absolute
being that formless dimensionless
oceanic-ness
field that is all of these different
waves of creation designs that are
being expressed as these illusory
individuals
and that's why people like alex gray
have the really beautiful visuals
things like the net of being if you go
and look that up
that will help as well with your
understanding
the energy of magnetism
is the elastic energy of expansion a
straining energy ever pushing toward the
inertial line of equalized pressures
which lies between any two masses while
the energy of electricity is ever
pulling toward the pulsing
heart the gravitational nucleus of every
mass
so magnetism inertial line of equalized
pressures electricity gravitational
nucleus of every mass
mind is the one substance thinking mind
is the one force
the formula of the locked potentials is
applied to the law of emanation orbits
the general active positive non-luminous
light units following centripetal orbits
to the nuclear
center of the next lower potential
all energy is caused by a disturbance in
inertia
everything that is is of everything else
that
is you'll see walter repeats
many things throughout because he's
trying to hammer
home some of the core concepts into the
reader
and he says them in different ways and
decorates them differently
takes them from different angles but
points to the same
mountain top from different faces
each octave is a separate effort for
supremacy made by the two opposing
forces
it's similar with the densities of
consciousness and the law of one
it's a very important analogy to draws
between
the seven densities of consciousness of
the law of one and also very similarly
between the octaves of musical notes
just like the coloration on the rainbow
it works very well with walter russell
as well here
orderly periodic accumulation of the
constant of energy into higher power
potentials at the expense of speed
life is merely an expression of the
generative power of centripetal force
to which death is but the degenerative
reaction
in the fourth octave the so-called
physical universe begins with but one of
its elements known to man the element
hydrogen
and in the law of one humans appear in
the third density and service the other
appears in that fourth density
illusory motion equals matter
varying states of motion illusion of
different substances
the elements of matter
the seven tones slash octave just like
the law of one
there are seven tones to each octave
again that lub dub of the heart the
inhale the exhale the prana
the life energy all direction is curved
all motion is spiral
the law generating matter seeks higher
pressure zones
and then here the law radiating matter
seeks lower pressure
zones and so you have this
expanding centrifugal radiation that's
magnetic discharging
and you have this contracting
centripetal generation that's electric
that's charging
and so that's the charging force that's
coming
in and then you have the the discharging
force that's going out
and that's that rhythmic balanced
interchange that's occurring rhythmic
balanced interchange that's occurring
so one of the most profound things to
understand is that rhythmic balanced
interchanges
a massive key to the nature
of existence here's another
visualization
female in preponderance where you have
the lowering potential the exhalation
the radiation
and the male in preponderance the
generation inhalation increasing
potential
this is the electrochemical working
chart
all mass is generated and regenerated by
a contractive pressure exerted
in the direction of its gravitative
center
the universal pulse all motion is
oscillatory
the one living being of which all nature
is a part
breathes the breath of life
and that's why when dj david johnson was
on our show on simulation design
his tool in the vu is the oscilloscope
all motion is oscillatory
again highly recommend watching that
show
the electromagnetic pulse beats of a
light unit
maybe 30 trillion to a second
so much to unpack still with those light
units and the pulsation
and that flux
of ratios creating the waves
the energy the universe is simple
truth is simple the more electric
potential a man can concentrate the more
work he can perform
very much like what we were just
describing pulls in non-stop
flux radiation generates and generation
radiates
all things can be what they desire to be
desire and effort to be
evolves into the reality of that desire
boom
and that's why things like the the
the law of attraction and things like
the secret
and things like uh creator consciousness
and manifesting are very
important because in the idea of the
thinking
universe all is mind and that is god
and this is light and energy
that it's very important to remember
that
the unfolding of everything has a lot to
do with
the way that you think your desire
what is that but also simultaneously
balanced in a middle way where you don't
have craving and attachment
at the same time all right
i started getting a little bit synthetic
here as well where i drew in concepts
like the universal wave function
so in many ways it's like the quantum
state of the totality of existence
all energy of motion expresses itself in
waves
all direction is therefore curved
there's a lot of analogies to draw
between these concepts because they're
all interplaying and intertwining the
dimensionless universe of inertia is
absolutely stable
one pulls inward from within the other
pushes outward from within
boom just like that
again very explain like i'm five if man
would picture the evolution and
evolution
of entire solar systems as mere
flashings of fire flies in the meadow
he would form a better concept of the
instability of solidity
that's right great analogy
the fireflies in the meadow just like
the entire solar systems
and just like the waves on the ocean and
again
the explain like i'm five is what i'm
trying to highlight here
a lot of the these breakdowns are very
like here mathematical relations right
and so
if you want to you can pause and check
these out yourself or again just buy the
book in the link yourself
and look them up to dive into them
universal white light of inertia
simulation in motion
again that universal white light that is
refracting
such a core perennial spiritual wisdom
opposing substances can be induced to
attract
each other by forcing a union under high
pressure or by using a catalyst as a
mediator
and that's why in the third density in
the law of one we have the evolutionary
catalyst for humans
every state of motion has not only its
own pressure zone but its own plane
there is no death man cannot die nor can
motion
end boom simple as light units separate
one from another they discharge each
other
consciousness whirlpools
in oceanic infinity
all effects of motion are whirlwinds
whirlpool that's why i put this also in
the bio it's such a critical thought
and here's that you know that's tornado
principle here
it's a very important one with those
whirlpools and whirlwinds and vortexes
just like what was being explained
earlier the periodicity of attraction
the periodicity of repulsion again
keywords here periodicity it's periodic
a rhythmic balanced interchange ratios
in flux
the universal constant of energy is
expressed by mass
in motion energy expressed by mass in
motion
there is a true position for every
potential
again all vortices
turn from west to east and their
abseils point to north
has an apex plural apices
again many of these are
the cube's motion important if you want
to
to look in more depth to actually
purchase yourself and go look at them
and see what sticks out for you as your
exegesis inertia overcomes motion
the creating universe is a reflection of
its concept in inertia
okay again ratios of poles in flux
equals energy again a rhythmic
balanced interchange
universal mathematics are ratios
of opposite expressions of the one force
again let's listen carefully universal
mathematics are ratios of
opposite expressions of the one force
again the universal math is simply put
the one
force in ratios of opposite expression
it's that simple
the one in two poles that has
different ratios of flux rhythmic
balanced interchange appearing as these
waves
the one ocean appearing as these waves
in the polarities
in ratios being expressed
ratios in flux is universal again
universal mathematics
all dimensions are pressure dimensions
all dimensions simultaneously expand and
contract in opposite directions of the
same ratio
fourth pressure zone third pressure zone
second pressure zone and first pressure
zone
the formula of the lock potentials in
universal ratios
tones vary in ratios which are absolute
and universal
okay
there's more of these
visualizations universe
equals energy in motion
the universal wave function
opposing electromagnetic cones of energy
another great way to put it
dense distance dimensions of energy of
tones within a wave
another great visualization
to charge and discharge here highly
recommend
supporting the university of science and
philosophy and walter russell
by the book check it out draw out your
own salient
points from it
nature's method of storing energy and
mass you have the integration
and the disintegration and the illusory
diversity and oneness
that we experience
to know the wave is to know the secret
of creation
boom love that the wave is nature's
method of transferring the dimensionless
concept of form in inertia
to dimensional form in mass in motion
by an impact of the energy of the
concept against the inertial plane
to know the wave is to know the secret
of creation
and that's why the universal wave
function
right is so critical and to be able to
sort of
understand what the quantum state of all
that is would be
how to take and represent that and how
to understand it also at these most
expressions of the one oceanicness
with the two poles in a rhythmic
balanced interchange as waves
again to know the wave is to know the
secret of creation not only at a level
of physics but at a level of metaphor
and spirituality with the ocean
at the same time it's fascinating
and here's another great way to put it
the wave equals
two opposed units such a simple way to
put it
all motion appears in mass and
disappears in plane
the wave is a spiral so good
a wave is not a single unit it is a
series of two opposed units
a wave is mass in opposition
in here we have the inertial line at the
top and the inertial line at the bottom
this is the pressure zone diagram all
mass to rotate and to revolve in spiral
orbits
and here's a good way to sort of
visualize it as you have this wave
you have this first pressure zone that's
created here
and here and then you have the second
pressure zone and the third
and fourth you have these pressure zones
that are occurring
and this is where you have these laws
like contracting
mass seeks higher pressure zones and you
have
expanding mass seeks lower pressure
zones
and so you see that
the universal reproductive octave
constant
that's a really good one
the universal reproductive octave
constant
waves equals energy in motion
i love that so simple waves equals
energy and motion
again very similar to that metaphor of
the ocean and the waves of the absolute
and its
infinite creative expression the
evolution of mass
from plane to sphere and its diffusion
back to plane
are by the way of the cone
and another great way to say it energy
equals polar ratios in flux
energy expresses itself by an apparent
division of its force into equal
opposites
of more and less again
those polar ratios
in flux the one expressing itself is
these polar ratios and flux creating
these waves of
creation designs and individuals
immersed in them experiencing them
that eternal coloration of awareness
again we're gonna make a separate video
on this but ego
and time are the two heaviest anchors
holding people back from
self-realization
what is the i without time
it's [ __ ] infinite time is the
measure of universal
repeativeness all phenomena of nature
are repeated
time is the interval between the
sequences of events
time belongs essentially to motion and
is not an attribute of substance
displacement and replacement are
universally simultaneous
i love that one
and another great way to put it the
universal seesaw
right that pendulum seesaw
simultaneity equals synthesis equals
joseph and the code of many colors
simultaneity is essential to the
maintenance of an equilibrium
in motion force has the illusion of
existence
you can see i'm drawing many complex
concepts into the same
arena to try and create a harmonization
between the perennial spiritual
traditions as well as the cutting edge
sciences
a universe of varying pressures
any force of the universe of dimension
is an opposing pressure force
light is the universal language the
colors of light are the letters of the
alphabet
so simply put combinations of the
letters of light
are the words of the language of light
all effects of motion absorb light and
give forth light
all light is a complexity of all colors
so good
mind creates that which mind thinks
energy is conceived in inertia
stored in mass and recorded in plane
the evolution of mass from plane to
sphere
again that appearance and disappearance
mass is generated into the appearance of
form by the attraction of gravitation
and is radiated into the disappearance
of form by the repulsion
of radiation
the generation of mass
generation decelerates rotation
and the degeneration of mass
degeneration accelerates rotation
evolution of mass electricity evolves
mass into the form of a true sphere and
magnetism devolves it into plane
the process is orderly and periodic
again
so simple
both forces meet in reproductive union
spiral waves are formed and all spiral
motion is born
i love it forces meet in reproductive
union boom
the two poles are constantly meeting in
reproductive union one
each of the opposing forces conquers the
other by simulating the
desire of the other all motion
characterized by oscillation
all masses rotate on their axes and
revolve around their gravitative centers
again these graphics are super duper
helpful explaining acceleration and
deceleration of rotation
so on one side you have this the
attractive pull of gravitation
that's coming in and on the other side
you have this repellent thrust of
radiation
going out so the gravitative pull
and the radiative push
the electropositive force of attraction
pulls inward from within
the electronegative force of repulsion
pushes outward from within
the opposing forces of gravitation and
radiation
so that simply put
the greater the radioactivity the
greater the power of mass to give
out its heat
the cosmic clock winds itself towards
solidity into the appearance of form
and unwinds itself toward nebulosity
into the disappearance of form the
process is orderly and periodic
again just the ocean and the waves guys
it's that simple
inhalations and exhalations heartbeats
i mean how simple is it all the codes
are right under our nose
okay and then this is very beautiful
it reminds me a lot of the lee groups
and the e8 lattice
signs of crystallography
crystallization chart the basic
principle of crystallization
in accord with the formula of locked
potentials
okay
the dimensionless universe knows neither
plane nor mass the universe of dimension
knows
infinite variety of both plane and mass
there you go again just so simply put
i love it all mass is an
aggregation of light units
here's an explanation of ionization
again you have the ionization increasing
and the ionization decreasing
that north and south that male female
negative positive centrifugal force
centripetal force
ionization is the process of
disintegration
all effects of motion obey the
orderliness of the formula of the locked
potentials
ionization is a disintegration effect of
motion
and the ratios of disintegration are in
the direct
of the universal as those of integration
are in the inverse
this was interesting valence equals
tonal relations
so the universal wave function described
in valence this was interesting the term
valence is a standard unit of tonal
relations
surveillance can be thought of here as
ratios in flux
which equals energy so valence describes
energy relative willingness
or unwillingness to unite with each
other it's fascinating
so all of those the one in harmonic
flux or rhythmic balanced interchange
into these different waves
is in a sense valence is energy
it can be described that way
all right come to a close here the
conclusion
the purpose of these writings
is to illumine the road leading to
eternal life
by knowledge of the journey through
illusion and back again to reality taken
by man
in his repeated adventures in time space
and motion
in order to illumine the way it is first
necessary to trace the simulations
reflections and illusions of the
apparently many substances
forms and things back to their base in
the reality of the one thing
the created universe is but an illusion
of the forms of ideas
thought out by mind
mind is the only real thing in the
universe and mind is all that is
thinking mind evolves ideas and
registers them in form
through motion i wrote here the
absolutes dream
all these different creation designs and
explorations
that which we call self is but the
changing form of idea
thought out by the unchanging formless
one
beautiful unchanging ocean and then all
the ideas of waves
when man learns that god is mind that
mind is the one living pulsing thinking
force and that he
is that force then man will have arrived
at another stage in his evolution
he is but a simulation of the idea of
himself being thought out in eternity
by himself then he will know the ecstasy
of inner thinking
i love walter russell it's so good
okay there is no death no darkness only
life in the universe
of light life light all that is
god is that just so long as man looks
for the god force outside of nature and
outside
of himself just so long as he bows in
fear to the personal deity of his early
inheritance
he will be the slave of his own
imaginings
boom to know that the universal force is
mined and that man and all else that
is his mind is to inspire man with the
ecstasy of inner thinking
i love it jesus knew the universal
language of light in all its fullness
he knew the ecstasy of inner thinking as
no man has ever known it
jesus knew the universality of all
things the oneness of all things he gave
that knowledge to the then
dull-witted brutal lustful loveless
world in his
much needed message of brotherly love he
lived again in john and paul
and potinus and all those messengers
who knew the light of universal thinking
jesus gave to man the one great message
of all time he taught the universality
of all things
in the white light of the universal one
of impartial love
from whose rulings there is no appeal
but only a few
could faintly understand
spirit of truth will again come to guide
you
into all truth and that's the cyclic
style of the cosmology of the buddhas
and the jesuses and the laotzes and the
confuciuses and
all of the hermeses and all these
people that have come to express the
love light truth over and over again
eternally to us to awaken us to pierce
the veil and self-realize
everything that is must be of everything
else that is
no two of anything all things are
universal
one and here's another great
visual you have that one
and you have the creating universe
appears from the one
and disappears into the one
the oceanicness expressed as waves
the eternal creative waves
of the one oceanicness
when he acquires the stability of
perfect balance in his thinking he will
be
ready for the light ecstasy of universal
thinking all presence and unity with the
one
and again a really good visualization
here
gravitation and radiation gravitation
the attraction of gravitation pulls
inward through
toward high pressures from low pressures
and radiation the repulsion of radiation
pushes outward toward low pressures from
high pressures within
and again i kind of wrote this it's cute
the absolute heartbeat
universe radiation universe radiation
the oroboros
all thinking is creating that which it
is thinking
no idea of mind has place or position in
time or space
all ideas universal all mass is
degenerated by its own radiation
all mass is generated by accumulation of
the universal constant of energy into
higher potential
that which is generated must be radiated
all
opposite effects of motion are
simultaneous in their expression
no state of motion ever began or ever
ended all masses both electric and
magnetic
all mass simultaneously expresses both
opposites of all effects of motion
again we've been doing many of these in
the direct path videos that you can
check out but it's an agentless
absolute infinitely expressing itself
again an agentless attributeless
absolute infinitely expressing itself
so the ocean the agentless attributeless
ocean
infinitely expresses itself creatively
as waves aka
creation designs physicalism humans
awareness
being colored eternally all
electromagnetic mass forms
into systems of units which revolve in
spiral orbits both centripetally toward
and centrifugally away from nuclear
centers
so well said electricity attracts
magnetism repels
all opposite effects of motion are
simultaneous
another critical one
and the greater the radioactivity the
greater the power of mass to give out
its heat
and then there are some revisions and
changes
that you'll see at the back and um we'll
just briefly say that the secret of
working
knowingly with god is another booklet
that helps
the universe itself is all light optics
is the true science of electricity
and then here's the university of
science and philosophy
the headquarters
and the sculpture gardens works of
walter and lau russell
beautiful in the university of science
and philosophy right there
and other books by walter russell go and
check them out the links in the bio
below the secret of light
a new concept of the universe the
message of the divine iliad the book
of early whisperings and there's many
many other ones there for you to check
out and
boom that's a wrap folks the universal
one incredible
all right well
i am so pumped that we got to
we got to do this together i'm glad that
we got to unpack this
um again i'm super grateful to
andy bittner for making the introduction
to walter russell's work
it's been extremely important for my
synthesis
and very important for d
very grateful for dj david johnson and
his continued influence as well on me
with this type of work
so again
really dive into this in depth
it's a massive synthesis of metaphysics
and idealism and consciousness and that
absolute
oceanic-ness with the way that it
expresses itself
creatively as these waves as these
physical
creation designs of illusory
individuation
and the science of the electromagnetism
of the general radiative forces
centripetal centrifugal and centripetal
the simultaneity of those
infinitely expressing itself and to
understand that rhythmic balanced
interchange there is critical those
ratios
influx that valence that energy
in motion that those waves of the ocean
are what this is it's what it's been
it's what it will continue doing forever
and ever
eternity so
it's beautiful he's eloquent walter
russell does a great job
and he's very much dj was telling me
last time we were
hanging on new year's eve that he hung
out with
tesla and mark twain and that that
the sort of ideas are obviously
very synergistic with them as well and
so to
in a sense uncover walter russell is a
very
important part of the journey
in piercing the veil and self-realizing
and also synthesizing
the consciousness metaphysics with the
way that it expresses itself as these
waves
of science that we investigate so
i love you very much thank you for
tuning in thanks for checking this out
check out
the links in the bio below again to the
university of science and philosophy
and also the link to all of walter
russell's books is down there
go and buy the universal one draw out
the salience yourself with your own
exegesis
go and re-listen to this and pause
several points and take notes as you
need as well
and that's all let me know how you feel
in the comments below i'd love to hear
from you
and subscribe if you haven't to the
channel like the video share the video
with those that
need to hear this as well let's
encourage more people to pierce the veil
and self-realize
and i love you thanks for tuning in
and we'll see you on
many more videos like this soon where we
do
other critical reviews and we're going
to
iron out the best optimal strategies
video and audio wise in doing so so
thank you and that's all
much love peace
you